so let's see if we can come up ways to
compute what 2.8 times four point seven
three is so pause this video and try to
work it out and actually I'll give you a
hint try to figure out just using the
digits not even paying attention to the
decimals the digits that the product
would have and then use estimation to
think about where to place the decimal
in your product so you get a reasonable
answer all right now let's do this
together so let's just imagine that we
were multiplying these numbers without
decimals so that would be a situation
where we would have 473 times 28 and so
we could try to compute that and so we
could think about let's multiply
everything times the 8 so 3 times 8 is
24 7 times 8 is 56 plus 2 is 58 and then
4 times 8 is 32 plus 5 is 37 and then we
could multiply everything times the 2
I'll cross those out so I don't get
confused 3 times 2 is going to be 6 and
we have to be very careful we are now in
the tens place so we want a zero here so
3 times 2 tens is going to be six tens 7
times 2 is 14 four times two is eight
plus one is nine we add everything two
together and we get 4 plus 0 is 4 8 plus
6 is 14 and then 1 plus 7 plus 4 is 12
and then we get 1 plus 3 is 4 plus 9 is
equal to 13 so we know that the final
answer has the digits 1 3 2 4 4 in that
order 1 3 2 4 4 so now we have to think
about where would we put a decimal for
this to be a reasonable answer and
here's where estimation is useful we
know that two point eight times four
point seven three is going to be roughly
equal to what
well two point eight is pretty close to
three so I'll estimate two point eight
as being three and four point seven
three is if I had to estimate it out say
hey it'd be pretty close to 5 so this
should be pretty close to 3 times 5 so
it should be close to 15 so if I were to
put the desk
there that's way more than 15 so that
doesn't seem reasonable even if I were
to put the decimal there one thousand
three hundred twenty four point four
still way more than fifteen far to put
the decimal they're still way more than
fifteen if I were to put the decimal
there hey that actually feels about
right thirteen and 244 thousands is is
approaching fifteen it's it's in the
ballpark and it's actually the closest
cuz if we were to put the decimal there
then we go to one point three two four
four so a lot less than fifteen so if we
want this to be roughly equal to fifteen
we definitely would want to put the
decimal right over there that is the
most reasonable the most reasonable
computation we can do because we know
the digits are going to be 1 3 2 4 4 and
this helps us put the decimal in the
future we're going to come up with ways
of doing it that where you don't
necessarily have to estimate but I
encourage you the estimation is always
key if you ever in your life forget some
type of method or process for
multiplying decimals
it's the estimation that allows you to
understand whether you're coming up with
a reasonable answer and this is really
important because the decimal there's
there's a remember reading a new story a
couple of years ago where someone put in
a stock trade where they got the decimal
wrong and because of that they
essentially sold 10 times as many shares
as they were supposed to it so they lost
hundreds of millions of dollars so
anyway decimals are important